things are heating up between kourtney
kardashian
and travis barker i love it a source
tells e.t
that the two have gotten way more
serious adding quote
this is the happiest courtney has been
in a while and her family is thrilled
for her courtney and travis's kids get
along great
and all have the best time together the
source says that court's been trying to
keep the relationship
as private as she can on social media
but they're both
super into each other and cute together
thank you
and while they may be trying to keep
their love private the new couple
recently traveled to the deer valley
resort in park city utah
on a skiing vacation with their kids and
the blink 182 drummer shared
several pics and clips from the trip
with his lady
[Music]
yeah don't blink or you just might miss
travis and courtney cuddling next to the
fire pit
and that that's the couple riding down
the slopes on a sled
the caption real is rare travis also
shared
this group shot with court his two kids
seventeen-year-old landon
and fifteen-year-old alabama who he
shares with his ex
shayna mookler and atiana de la hoya
shayna's 22 year old daughter from a
previous relationship
and if all that wasn't cute enough the
fam had some fun doing tick tocks past
the phone challenge
passing the phone to somebody who can't
get acrylic i'm passing the phone to
somebody that doesn't let me do anything
wait i'm passing the phone to my
boyfriend
yeah court referred to travis as her
boyfriend for the first time since they
were linked back in january
and after their getaway they spent some
quality time with the kardashian jenners
for easter
oh my gosh i just woke up on this easter
sunday
and came into the kitchen and my mom
treats easter like it's christmas you
guys have no idea
the fam's famous momager kris jenner
gifted her six kiddos with
matching golf clubs and shared that
travis was already putting them to use
on the course
with corey gamble tristan thompson and
travis scott
travis opened up about his relationship
with court during an appearance on the
drew barrymore show in march
and said their love comes naturally
since they're both parents
i would you know like date girls that
didn't have kids and i find it kind of
hard because they would i think they
would have trouble understanding like
well why
why don't you want to go to dinner every
night with me or why don't you want to
see me every night
and now i'm
you know spending time with a woman
who's like a great mom
who's like a great friend and i just
you don't have to worry about any of
those things it just comes naturally